Spring Break this movie is something
else it has a lot going for it
to start off it's definitely unique this
movie is a party movie yet there feels
like there's a lot of danger behind it
it's not like weekend at Bernie's or The
Hangover this film is very realistic
very raw there's a lot of drinking a lot
of pot a lot of cocaine a lot of tits
and a lot of party guys it really feels
like spring break then there's violence
and it's pretty damn violent even when
it's not being violent
it still feels violent so it's a weird
[ __ ] movie but I loved it for some
reason what I enjoyed most about this
film is that the entire movie felt like
we were in a dream the whole thing moves
sort of like I hypnotic Christopher
Nolan type a montage I'm talking about
the whole thing like every scene the
whole thing that really pulls you into
this world and it's like you're tripping
out on this movie there's so many themes
in this movie chasing the dream looking
for that extreme party hi escaping from
reality
it was great to watch a movie that truly
captured those emotions not just for the
actors but with the directing the
writing the editing the cinematography
and the music this movie is especially
open to interpretation
some people will love this movie and
some people will hate this movie Selena
Gomez does a great job in this movie
when she was on was just a waverly place
I felt uncomfortable saying this but now
after watching this movie I'm proud to
say I wanna [ __ ] Selena Gomez hopefully
she watches this review the other girls
are very much two-dimensional
practically no different from the next
but I think that's the point of the
characters is how empty their lives
really are James Franco embodies the
role of this gangster Spring Break he
does such a believable job with a
character that could have easily just
been laughed at the movie is simple yet
it's so damn wildly unique my only real
issue with this movie is that an
occasion
rags and I don't quite agree with the
ending but you know what it's trashy
it's hypnotic it's sexy it's
exploitative it's violent I really want
to [ __ ] Selena Gomez and let's not
forget poor hot [ __ ] in a bikini for
an hour and a half plus a lot of movies
it's quite possibly the best Spring
Break movie ever let me get straight to
the point here all in all I gotta say
Spring Breakers got it right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
video please go ahead and tell me your
points below in the comment box about
Spring Breakers and if you want to see
more in-depth review of the movie go
ahead and check out my show called
reasons to see that I do with my buddy
Jerry where we give you reasons to see
and not to see Spring Breakers and last
but not least if you want to get updated
every time a new review is out go ahead
and subscribe to my channel